and apparently this is based on a book
series I didn't know that by a guy which
I was yeah and their franchise they want
to make a franchise out of this which
makes sense even more crazy rich asian
my girlfriend whispered over to me in
the movie going this is what fifty
shades failed to do and I was like what
are you talking about well then I
watched I'm looking back and I'm like oh
yeah because he's super rich dude your
regular girl from New York who falls in
love with the rich guy to get used to
the whirlwind yeah yeah all the [ __ ] you
didn't ask for when you just wanted to
have a relationship yeah yeah there's
like no sex in this movie but this movie
does succeed in that fashion to a reject
nation its Greg Alba here and I'm John
Humphrey John is the Asian assign know
I'm the whitest guy I know and we saw
the movie crazy rich Asians
I saw crazy rich Asians although it's
like a lone white dude I support this I
actually haven't talked with you for one
second about what you thought of the
movie oh yeah we'll get ready cuz
there's gonna be a whole lot controversy
in this movie do you ever see a trailer
no I never seven hold this I feel like
if we don't do a reaction for it I'm
probably not going to watch the trailer
unless it happens to play before a movie
had a movie theater a I was like hearing
all these reports about how a great
cinema scored has that brought a tomato
score audience score on Rotten Tomatoes
and then the box office mojo reports
were talking about how this movie is
expected to do very well this weekend
Lots agents in the world and I was
thinking about it and I'm like I'm half
asian
I should go watch this movie III should
do it yeah you know even though I know
nothing about it and I haven't seen a
trailer I should go check this film out
I go to the theater it is packed the
movie starts and about five minutes into
this film I'm like I think I'm gonna
love this movie yeah kind of new I'm
kind of loved the hell out of this film
I'm half Filipino hence the Batman
colors of the Filipino flag that I'm
representing today and I have Asian
friends in this movies primarily Chinese
care
actually there's a Filipino act the guy
plays Oliver's a Filipino actor actually
I have Chinese blood in me actually but
as a holder thing transfusion and being
Filipino in this day and age you know
it's like there's always that debate
I've heard for the past few years or
Filipinos really Asian or Pacific
Islanders bottom line I grew up feeling
like I'm Asian and everyone identified
me his half Asian I just identify as
Asian okay I'm on that side that
believes it before we get to a whole
debate about it and I grew up primarily
with my Asian side looking at the
relatives and stuff I don't have crazy
rich relatives but identifying with the
Constance Wu character of being
asian-american but then being with
people who are actually from Asia I
really felt for that side yo on the
outside or white on the inside there
were definitely elements to the cultures
that I really identify with and in terms
of Asian representation I felt really
proud for the Asian community watching
this movie because you know you got
American Asian you got Asian Asian you
got British Asian you got all variety of
Asians in this movie couldn't help but
think how many minds are about to be
blown by the the sheer volume of young
people with British accents yeah the
scary movie genre is definitely the best
genre to break out with you didn't
really prove yourself you know all the
directors that I am ma so getting that
that pride out of the way but I'll move
on to the movie because yeah I did watch
this and I and I was really happy for
the Asian community especially because
no one in this movie is through martial
arts it's different like one scene but
it's not even a character an actual
character to see a little joke that's it
last a second even at Michelle Yeoh here
who was up who was used to be a very
famous martial artists upper star she's
not doing any martial arts in this movie
and I was it does emotional Marcille yes
okay but usually when you watch Asians
in American movies they're there to do
martial arts
or there's a joke about it the movie
itself
I really did enjoy a lot I think it is a
very funny movie it's a very romantic
movie it's a clever movie that's my
basic thought on it what about you oh
yeah no I totally agree I mean I guess
you'd categorize this as a romantic
comedy and what kind of swept me up in
it is I really appreciate the romantic
comedies that bother to include the
drama side a little bit more than just
your cookie cutter 90-minute one and I
also really enjoy the kind that take
almost like a class approach to when
it's not just about boy meets girl and
the difficulties they run into yeah it's
like there are cultural elements to the
story that I always really appreciate
with films like this so yeah I really
got swept up and I think it took me a
little longer to get in the groove of
the movie when I got there man I I had a
great time with this I've also really
touched me too there's a very specific
element here that I think being
asian-american that I really identified
with there talking about and Asia
parents you know really do what they can
to guide their their children's careers
look after them as a very traditional
looking out for the good of the family
overall like there are lots of
consideration exactly and I definitely
identify with that factor I'm the only
one on my Asian side along with my
brother who wants to you know pursue
things that are thread that keeps coming
up in whether you should follow your
passions or or try not to cause a scene
or or try to consider all the people
around you first a big part of this film
comes down to I think the director and
the cast's I mean this year main
ingredients of any movie the director
Jon M Chu obviously has a really big
understanding of the cultural
differences here I like his style
because he has style like really snappy
it's snappy there are times where his
direction reminded me of a Wes Anderson
movie yeah especially in those like wide
really very Center yeah yeah there's a
lot of really expressive use of framing
in in both subtle and more immediately
recognizable way oh it's definite and
they're also like animations and and
creative editing you know tricks oh yeah
Constance Wu is the main character
she's incredible like your attorney
performance watching this movie kind of
made me think of
what My Big Fat Greek Wedding must have
been like for Greek people who this must
be what it's like for Asian people
specifically Chinese people yeah her
character is so layered in as I think
for Asian Americans is the one you can
identify with I'm not gonna go out there
and say every Asian American could
identify with this movie because it's a
very ludicrous plot that you're dealing
with real crazy real rich Asian people
yeah that's not the scenario for every
Asian American person will never be in
any of these situations yeah so I'm not
gonna say every Asian American can
identify with it but it's a good step
and then there's even the male
counterpart I don't know if he's
actually British but he is Asian he's
certainly charming enough that I could
stick Henry Golding as the main guy Nick
Young know we're a few minutes into this
really haven't gone over the plot at all
basically she's chinese-american so you
know it's a lot of like she has to try
to get the approval and acceptance not
only of the you know the Asian culture
side trying to understand an Asian
American but also you know she doesn't
come from wealth at all it's kind of
like Meet the Parents Meets My Big Fat
Greek Wedding with an Asian mixture
there's many characters in there that
really stand out Michelle Yeoh is a
Elinor Young who is essentially the
antagonist of the movie she's the one
you you know they have to please and
she's like the ruler of most of that
approval she so believable
she really embodies this role there's a
guy that reserved but still the
intensity coming whew it you know and
there's a lot of siblings for Nick Young
and cousins relatives and then the
cousin to Nick Young the standout
performer of the extended family would
have to definitely be Jemma Chan as
Astrid who's works in the fashion
business they're all very successful
people yeah yeah they're like royalty of
grades successful yeah and she is you
know without giving away plot points
she's one of the more layered characters
out of the supporting cast the highlight
comedic performance the one that easily
garnered the biggest laughs Aquafina was
my very favorite and this is my first
exposure to her at all right look at her
name I've seen her face my first
exposure to her was her reading a mean
tweet on Jimmy Kimmel boys have a 58
year old divorce attorney no so I don't
know any of her words honestly whoa ah
that was that was some an amazing comedy
she had in this film this her
performance is the thing that truly made
me curious to go check out ocean's 8 but
yeah she brings a lot of life and
personality to the screen and she also
like her family characters too like Kim
Jong is in there as her dad and stuff
they bring you a lot of direct comedy to
things and also a lot of relief to
whenever she's on screen you're always a
little relief yeah yeah oh definitely
well she's the best friend - Constance
Woo's character it has a lot of romantic
comedy tropes there's certain elements
in here where certain characters were
introduced watch this with my girlfriend
and immediately we would go oh this is
what's gonna happen this is like the
second they're introduced we were like
we know what the reveal is gonna be so
it's not gonna be a surprise at all but
that doesn't really affect the movie
because the characters are so well
fleshed out in this film yeah and they
choose a lot of more human moments than
you would expect from the kind of movie
that this is necessarily like there are
a lot of things that could have been
cheap plot points that actually get a
little bit of nuance and it get to feel
lived in so no character really ever
feels one-dimensional or slide it in any
way or like a lot device almost every
major beat it does pretty much follow
it's predictable in that fashion at the
same time I kind of like that it showed
that you could put Asian actors in these
movies that usually star white people in
these romantic comedies and it still
works out just fine yes that works out
great it doesn't have to be like they're
all doing kung-fu or whatever yeah yeah
you could just have them be real people
and it'll still work out fine yeah I
think this is definitely one of those
movies whose quality shines out in the
execution and in just the handling
overall because yeah there are a lot of
things that you can predict you can see
coming that are kind of of a structural
format but again the cultural aspects
that they fill in the blanks with and
also the way that they actually bother
to have some human scene like that's the
thing is I wouldn't
call this a romantic comedy because that
makes it least me think of you know 90
minutes and you know fun and jokes and
stuff yeah yeah but this slapstick you
know this feels like you authentic to a
certain degree yeah yeah when it's
over-the-top
you know it's not so over-the-top that
like usually the the more main
characters want to leave the
over-the-top situation to get to more
you know real stuff no there's a lot of
laughter that I think is omitted from
being able to actually identify with
what's going on even if you're not Asian
I think there's plenty of relationship
moments that you can just identify with
that'll make you laugh yeah I think this
one has an amazing heart I think it has
wonderful performances it's tightly
directed and tightly edited if you guys
want to have a really just a delightful
time at the theaters get in touch with
some good messages and whatever I mean
you just go watch this movie you want to
laugh a lot cry a little bit feel a lot
of things have a great time definitely
record this is a highly recommended
movie online all right guys well what is
your favorite martial arts action movie
what Asian actor do you think should
come to the States just like a great
Asian actor not even martial artist one
who's someone that we should be keeping
on the lookout for anyway guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation please
click that notification bail because
subscribe button suck and check us on
patreon because we got full a TV show
reactions weekly Q&A and music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron objected
[Music]